well if you're someone who likes to
decorate for the holidays you know
getting festive it can what can really
rack up you know how about decking the
halls for half off that's not too shabby
Candace Charles is live at a local store
called Santa's wrap and this is all they
do Candace help us sparkle on a budget
good morning
absolutely John good morning to you to
the
got you covered for an affordable price
of course everything here in Santa's
wrap 50 off some of the things that you
would see in department stores also here
and a lot cheaper up have the great mind
behind one of them at least Beth Tom
thank you so much for joining us now
we're in front of kind of a sea theme we
have multiple themes here for the
holidays not only the red and green you
would think of tell us about it this is
huge for us I'm from Hawaii I used to
own Price Busters over there and my
vendor said you cannot sell this in
Vegas it's one of our best themes so
awesome okay now tell us about the other
things you have in here as well we have
this we have retro we have boho we do
have the traditional red and green we do
a lot of Glitz and Glam a lot of gold I
showed you that ornament the silver
ornament with the gems all over it I
love it I love it I love all those
Sparkles what's trending this year what
are folks getting a lot of gnomes a lot
of sparkles
um sea life obviously they there's a lot
of people that still like the
traditional red and green I mean you're
always going to sell a red ball right
absolutely okay for the person I would
like to save a little bit of money and
for those who like to spend a lot what
is the range how much can you go in here
and spin well
if you look at the store you could
probably spend a million dollars
absolutely Heather don't do that or you
could come in here and buy an ornament
for a dollar and a half or a gift I
showed you those gifts four dollars yeah
they're one of a kind special gifts they
really are something that you could hold
on to Forever tell us a little bit about
the gifts yeah eighty percent of what we
carry is one of a kind twenty percent
has some continuity so when you're
buying something if you if you sit here
and look at these here's a cute little
gift right here Christmas by the Sea
where I want to be right ask anybody
who's where I want to be by the sea I
know I got it and this little guy is
canvas and he's seven dollars seven
dollars Beth I don't know how you do it
but this is an amazing story thank you
so much for having us here this morning
and joining us this bright and early now
they're open Tuesday through Sunday 10
a.m they'll be open here at 10 A.M and
really is a great experience besides
coming here and shopping the folks are
very nice they have a bunch of regulars
that come here but they have a lot of
new people coming right now because as I
mentioned everything in the store is
fifty percent off of course we got you
covered with all the details on our
website newsnow.com that's hours
directions all that good stuff on our
website again 8newsnow.com for now live
from Santa's Rock I'm Candace Charles
now